>>Male Presenter: This talk is brought to
you by Googlers for Optimize Your Life, Google's
campaign to build the happiest and healthiest
workforce on the planet.
So, Jeff is a former US Olympian in the ten
thousand meters.
He's written numerous books, notable "Jeff
Galloway's Book on Running", and is a frequent
writer for "Runner's World" magazine."
He's a life-long runner and believes that
everyone is capable of a successful running
career.
Today, Jeff will briefly talk about his experiences,
will answer your questions in pursuit of running
injury-free.
I had the unique opportunity to attend the
Galloway School in Atlanta, Georgia, in high
school--a school founded by Jeff's father,
Elliot Galloway.
Both of Jeff's sons were classmates of mine,
which had the distinct advantage of having
Jeff Galloway as one of your track coaches.
[laughter]
Not a bad deal.
During my senior year, Jeff helped our track
team reach some really amazing goals.
Personally, running a sub-five mile and sending
a number of people to the Georgia State finals.
So, it was a really, really good experience.
As you can imagine, Jeff has lots of stories
to tell from running with Steve Prefontaine
and Frank Shorter in the '72 Olympics in Munich
to his more recent ventures, hosting all kinds
of running programs all over the world.
I know I'm not alone in saying Jeff is a truly
inspirational person who cares deeply about
healthy living and running injury-free.
His unique run/walk/run training programs
have helped thousands of people complete running
of all distances.
He's one of the most humble people you'll
ever meet.
[chuckles]
And I'm really glad that we were able to bring
him here today.
So, please join me in welcoming Jeff Galloway
to Google.
[applause]
>>Jeff Galloway: OK.
I'm on a little bit of a string here.
Is this OK?
>>Female #1: Yeah, great.
>>Jeff Galloway: Great.
OK.
Yes.
I was on the Olympic team in 1972.
And a lot of people accuse me of being the
Forrest Gump of running because before running
was anything at all, I was out there and I
had already gotten hooked on it.
But I will tell you, there are worse things
to get hooked on.
As a 13-year old, I was a fat kid.
My dad was in the Navy.
I'd gone to 13 schools and I'd been able to
slink out of doing regular physical activity
due to a lot of excuses.
And then reality hit when my father got out
of active duty in the Navy.
And we went to a school that required boys
to go out for athletics after school.
I'd gotten to know some of the other lazy
kids in school.
So, I asked them what they were gonna go out
for during the winter.
And most of them were choosing winter cross-country.
I said, "That can't be easy."
And they said, "It is because the cross-country
coach is the most lenient in the school.
And all you have to do is lie to him.
Tell him that you're gonna run in the woods
and you can go out and hide in the woods."
[laughter]
Two hundred yards is all you have to run.
So, I did that for two days.
And as fate would have it, on the third day,
an older kid that I liked came up to me and
said, "Galloway, you're running with us today."
Well, I had my strategy all set up.
I was gonna reach the edge of the woods, grab
my hamstring, and say, "I'm injured.
I can't go on."
But they started telling jokes and then they
started telling gossip about the teachers.
And I just found myself lured on, day by day,
to go another half mile.
And even--.
The two things that I discovered right away,
I felt better even after the worst days, the
most exhausting days, than I used to feel
all week long.
There was something going on up in the brain
that I liked and I liked a lot.
Secondly, the friends I was meeting were the
first real friends I had ever met.
And we argued with one another.
We shared experiences.
We really got to know one another.
Fifty-three years later, we're still the closest
friends.
And the fact is that there's a lot of things
that go on in mind, body, and spirit when
we run that don't occur in most other activities
in life.
I'm here mainly to help you.
I want to be available for any questions.
If you do not understand my Atlanta accent,
John can come up and translate.
But seriously, if you'd like anything clarified
right on the spur of the moment, simply raise
your hand.
I'm here for you.
Barbara, who's hiding out in the corner over
there, we do a lot of clinics together.
We just came up from Carmel.
And I have to tell you that it was extremely
unlikely when I started running in the '50s
and '60s that there would ever be retreats
for running or these massive events that you
have today.
And I'm very proud to say that I am partially
to blame for that.
And I'm accused of that all the time because
of run/walk/run.
So, I'm gonna tell you a bit about run/walk/run,
how it came to be, and then the principles
behind it.
And then, I can apply any solutions to problems
you're having by using that as one of the
methods.
In 1973, I started my running store called
"Phidippides."
And as far as I know, it was the first running
store that was purely running in the country.
Anyway, we didn't have much business in 1973
in running.
There were very few people running.
It was really a stupid business idea to do.
[laughter]
We didn't really get a regular profit going
for ten years.
And so, I had to figure out other things to
try to bring people in the store and then
have side businesses in running.
So, that's why I started doing our running
retreats and running groups.
We now have those in 90 cities around the
US.
We also have consultations that we do on a
regular basis.
And things like Carmel.
But in all of this, what I learned I applied
to the next set of advice and the next book
that I wrote on it.
So, what I'm telling you today is not based
on the type of training that I used before
the 1972 Olympics.
And it's not what I use per se as I tried
to get faster.
It's the compiling results from over 300 thousand
people that I have advised and had in our
various training programs and retreats.
And 90 percent of them have gotten back to
me to tell me how the advice works.
So, I'm very confident that most of you will
have some solutions--.
I'll have some solutions for you based on
this track record.
But in 1973, I was asked to teach a class
in beginning running.
And when I convened the class of 22, none
of them had been doing any running for at
least five years.
And so, this was true beginners.
I knew that I didn't want to run them very
much because I didn't want them to get injured
because I wanted them to be customers in my
store.
So, anyway, we did a lot of walking.
There was one group that was self-proclaimed
basket case physical specimens and they were
mostly walkers with a little running.
And then we had another set of young guys
that did other sports and they progressed
pretty rapidly and didn't do very much walking
at the end of the program.
And there was middle group, too.
But at the end of the ten-week class, every
one of those folks finished either a 5 or
a 10K.
The biggest thing for me is that there were
no injuries.
I had never been with a group of 20 or more
runners for ten weeks where there wasn't any
injuries.
And I realized that the walk breaks were the
buffer zones.
They were the shock absorbers to the system.
They allowed the body to adapt.
And from that point on, I used the run/walk/run
method.
It has evolved greatly since that time.
Today, what I'm finding is the ratios of running
to walking will allow your body to adapt.
And therefore, you don't have to crash on
the bed or the couch all afternoon after a
long run, or in some cases, a short run.
So, the amazing other factors are quicker
recovery and the ability to run faster in
races.
In marathons, I've studied this for numerous
surveys and found that the average person
who has been running marathons continuously--ten
or more-when he or she shifts to run/walk/run,
experiences an average of 13 minutes faster
with run/walk/run.
And I'll tell you where it is.
It's in the end.
If you conserve your resources early, then
you're the one that feels great in the end.
You're passing people.
And I know it's tough to have to pass those
poor people in the latter stages of a race,
but you know, somebody has to do it.
And I will tell you, psychologically it's
better to be the passer rather than the passee.
Now, the other thing I wanted to say very
clearly is that I'm not trying to drag anyone
kicking and screaming into run/walk/run.
It has many benefits.
It's as close of a panacea as I've found in
running to reducing or eliminating injury
and eliminating fatigue and allowing you to
have a life outside of just running.
But if you apply the principles that I've
come up with and don't even use run/walk/run,
there's still several other major benefits.
But run/walk/run has been the greatest single
thing I've found to allow people to keep away
from injury and to reach their goals, and
to be strong all the way to the finish.
Currently, our ratios are as follows: At eight
minutes per mile, run for four minutes and
walk for 30 seconds.
For nine minutes per mile, it's a four and
one ratio.
Ten minutes per mile is three in one.
Eleven minutes per mile is two and a half
and one.
Twelve minutes per mile, two and one.
Thirteen minutes per mile, one and one.
Fourteen minutes per mile, 30 seconds and
30 seconds.
We take beginners and we do as I did back
in 1973.
We will start them out with five to ten seconds
of running and the rest of the minute walking.
And what I found is the body can adapt to
that in practically every single case.
So, if you have friends that wanna get into
running, suggest that they only take it in
small doses first.
And then, the body will thank them.
And the mind will thank them, too.
And they won't get overwhelmed.
Any questions so far?
Yes.
>>MALE #1: [inaudible].
>>Jeff Galloway: I have written a book called,
"Fit Kids, Smarter Kids" for that very issue.
And the biggest single lesson I learned in
the research, which was really delivered to
me by a lot of folks at the CDC in Atlanta,
who specialize in this area of kids, is that
the brain is the greatest thing where you
get the most benefit in kids that exercise.
And the studies are rampant out there showing
better learning, quicker learning, a better
head start on things, the unlocking of the
circuits in the brain that solve problems.
Mainly because what running does particularly,
is it stimulates frontal lobe activity--the
executive brain--and this is true with kids
and adults.
And it really does allow for the brain to
really grow up quicker in terms of solving
problems.
But the key is not to burn kids out.
And so, you really have to take small doses
first because kids are able to run farther
and faster than they should be doing.
And if you let them go too far, too fast,
too soon, they can get psychologically burned
out and later on, not want to think about
running again.
So, make it fun.
Make it playful.
Have rewards.
And don't overdo it.
And then, you can have a lifelong exerciser
that's smart.
And that's real good.
I like that.
Yes.
>>MALE #2: [ inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: The question is relating
to half-marathons and marathons and how you
would use the ratios that I just mentioned.
Very appropriate because a lot of people get
confused as to when they should they be using
one ratio or another.
I try to make it simple.
And the simple rule is whatever pace you're
running that day would then determine what
ratio you would be using.
For example, if you're gonna run a training
run-- it's 12 minutes per mile-- then two
and one would be the most ratio that you would
want to do.
There are a lot of people that use one and
one at 12 minutes and some that use 30:30,
30 seconds, 30 seconds, also.
But if you're running a race faster than that
at say, ten minutes per mile, then a three
and one ratio, or sometimes a two in one ratio
has been the best way to do that.
And again, when you have a ratio of three
and one, you can also do 90 seconds, 30 seconds,
or 60 seconds, 20 seconds.
And more and more, folks are finding that
they actually run faster when they drop down
instead of going up in the amount of running.
Let me just go over a couple more principles
and then I really want to get to any questions
you have about anything, including nutrition,
areas of beginners, trying to break through
barriers, run faster in races, or whatever
it is that you want to do.
I want to get--.
I'll be here for any of you.
And if there are any questions about women's
issues, my wife, Barbara, is here.
We wrote that book together.
And when I edited her stuff on women's running
and the problems that women have, I learned
far more about women than I wanted to know.
But there are a lot of problems that women
perceive are deal-killers and they really
are not deal-killers.
There are solutions to practically every single
problem that I have ever found in running.
Now, the other principles.
When you're training for a long event, the
best single training component that will help
you more is a long run.
And I found that slowing down on those long
runs is crucial if you want to avoid long-term
recovery and also the hitting of the wall
and injuries.
So, the rule of thumb is that you should run
at least two minutes per mile slower on long
runs than you can currently run in your race.
The Kenyans actually run three to four minutes
per mile slower on their long runs than they
run in their marathons.
And you know if it's good enough for the Kenyans--.
[laughter]
And this is a dirty little secret that has
been around for generations.
The Kenyans in my generation, back in the
70s at the World Class level, were running
often ten minutes per mile when they were
racing at five minutes per mile.
And I said, "Oh, that's way too slow."
Of course, the Kenyans were whipping my butt.
And I should've been thinking about that.
But the fact is that slow, long runs are not
gonna hurt you.
They will help you.
You'll recover faster and you have much lower
chance of having problems with slower runs.
And whether you take walk breaks or not, a
slow run is definitely recommended.
Now, building the long--.
Just one second.
Building the long run up to at least the distance
of your race has been shown to produce a great
deal of improvement if you haven't been doing
that.
And marathons?
Those who used to run no more than 20 miles
in preparation for a marathon, when they go
up to our recommended Galloway 26-mile training
run, there's an average of 15 minute improvement.
Fifteen minutes from increasing the length
of that last long run.
One thing that has surprised me over the years
for marathoners, when people go from our 26-miler
and want to improve to say, qualify for Boston
or set a personal record or beat that obnoxious
person in their neighborhood that's running
faster than they are in a marathon and go
up to 29 miles, there's an average of 11 minutes
of improvement.
So, there's a huge amount of improvement out
there if you haven't been going these long
distances before the races that you have.
Yes, sir.
>>MALE #3: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: The question is about footwear
and the trend currently to go to barefooted
or minimal shoe use as being sort of a superior
way to run.
Well, a lot of people assume, due to some
of the articles and book, "Born to Run," that
this is a new thing.
But I have been running for 53 years and I've
seen the fad of minimal shoe, barefooted running
come and go five times.
About every ten years, there will be something
in the media about it and people will get
jazzed up.
Runners will go out and try it.
And most times, they will only do a little
bit of it at first and it feels good.
You know, the feet tingle, but it's OK.
So then, they go out and do a lot more or
buy a pair of Vibrams and go out in pavement
and the foot breaks or the leg breaks.
And they have to take six to eight months
off from running.
They tell their friends that that's why they
had to take this time off.
So, the trend and the fad goes away and this
fad will go away.
Now, there are some shoes that are more minimal
that work for a small section of the population.
And that's why there's so many models of shoes
today.
But I strongly caution the general population
to think that having less heel on a shoe or
less sole and less build-up on the shoe is
going to help you because I've heard from
thousands already that have been injured by
going into those shoes.
And then, when they shift back to a conventional
shoe, the injuries go away.
The shoes today are amazing compared with
shoes 15, 20, 30 years ago in how they reduce
injuries.
And so, the contentions in some of these articles
and books that regular shoes cause injuries
is not supported by the experience nor the
prevailing research on that subject.
Yes, sir.
>>MALE #4: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: The surface?
Whether--.
What type of surface you--?
Does it matter?
>>MALE #4: Yes.
>>Jeff Galloway: The question is about the
surface and does it matter when you're warming
up or whether you're running on it.
Shoes and walk breaks act as shock absorbers
even on the hardest of surfaces.
So, I've really not found anything inherently
wrong with running on pavement.
If the shoe is good enough for you and the
walk break ratio is right for you, both of
these act as shock absorbers on your system.
And on hard pavement, if you don't tend to
like that, then you can just take walk breaks
more frequently.
And that almost always does away with the
extra pounding.
>>MALE #5: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: That was your question, too?
OK, great.
Yes.
>>MALE #6: What's your take on post-run stretching
compared to [inaudible]?
>>Jeff Galloway: What type of stretching?
>>MALE #6: Stretching after.
>>Jeff Galloway: Just regular stretching.
OK.
Yeah, OK.
The question is about stretching.
What is my take on stretching?
I used to be a huge advocate for stretching.
That was before I looked into the research
about it.
Basically, during my era leading up to the
'72 Olympic Games, nobody in distance stretched.
It was not part of the culture at all.
In the mid-70s, a lot of football coaches
started coaching track teams and they had
been using stretching effectively for football
teams.
And they started incorporating that on the
track teams.
And stretching became a way of life for running.
But it was an old husband's tale.
I looked into the research about ten years
ago on this and believe it or not, there's
not a study anywhere showing that stretching
has any benefit whatsoever for distance running.
However now, there are dozens of studies showing
that distance runners who stretch have more
injuries.
The injuries last longer and the injuries
don't tend to heal.
So, my children, I am going to absolve you
of all guilt for never stretching.
[laughter]
Anything else right now?
Yeah.
>>FEMALE #2: [inaudible].
>>Jeff Galloway: There's no evidence that
post-stretching has any benefit whatsoever.
And unfortunately, I hear the negatives.
I average hearing from over a hundred runners
a day.
And about a third of those are injury problems.
And a high percentage are those that stretch
and a high percentage of those are those that
stretch after a run.
So, there's inherently beneficial in stretching
before, after, during, at night, in the morning,
or any time.
And so, without any benefit and a lot of stuff
that's out there showing that stretching has
detrimental aspects, I'm gonna just not recommend
it.
>>MALE #7: Do you also recommend concurrent
strength training [inaudible]?
>>Jeff Galloway: In my book, "Running Until
You're 100," I went into several databases.
And one of them was the effects of various
types of exercises.
And if you collect all these studies, long-term,
on the various exercise modes, running has
been studied a little more than other activities.
But the bottom line is that any exercise we
do is gonna tend to be good for us because
it engages circuits in the brain that keep
us active and keep working and keep the body
working at better capacity year after year,
even into the 80s and 90s.
We don't know that much about the 100s yet.
But they're a growing number.
The fastest age group in running today is
the over 80 group percentage-wise.
And it's really neat to see these folks.
Anyway, bottom line is strength training is
not really gonna help your running, but it
can help your posture if you have postural
exercises that work for you.
And the ones that I use are the crunch for
the front part of the body and arm running,
hand-rolled weights in the standing position.
Just like this.
Strengthens the shoulders, the neck, the muscles
up and down the spine to provide a backup
strengthening support for the spine.
And when you have the right strength activities
for you, it doesn't take much time, but you
tend to stay upright for a longer period of
time.
And I think that's a good thing.
I'm in favor of being upright.
Yes.
>>MALE #8: [ inaudible].
>>Jeff Galloway: Recovering from injury.
Yes.
My first 20 years, I experienced hundreds
of injuries.
About every 20 days, I came down with an injury.
And then, in 1978, I decided that I probably
was not gonna run any faster than I had run.
And so, I started backing off the intensity.
I stopped stretching and I found that walk
breaks that I had been advising people to
do worked for me, too.
And my goal became to run injury-free.
And I knew, even as of that time that the
walk breaks were probably the very best way
to stay injury-free.
So, with that as my new goal, I decided to
take walk breaks on virtually every run.
Well, 33 years later, I'm proud to say I haven't
had a single running injury.
So, those who say, "Well, if you run, you're
gonna get injured," not true.
I'm not alone.
I've heard from dozens of people who've been
running for over 40 years.
And for most of that time, once they've put
together the right formula, have not had injuries.
So, it is very possible to stay away from
that.
But coming back from an injury, you want to
do what you can to stay fit while you're injured.
Walking, usually, is an appropriate activity.
A few injuries won't allow it.
But I've had a number of e-coach clients that
I have actually walked their long runs when
they've had a running injury and they've maintained
all the endurance that they needed as one
would get from a long run.
So, walking is a good mode.
Running in water is another activity that
can keep you in good running shape and allow
you to transition back sooner.
Once you start back, it's best to build your
walk up to 30 minutes first.
And then start integrating these small amounts
of running into each minute of walking.
Some people can come back fairly fast.
Some can come back a little slower.
I've actually found that on most of the clients
that I've worked with, if they've gotten injured,
that they can keep running as long as they
stay below the threshold of further irritations.
So, someone who was doing a five and one--run
five minutes, walk one--often can go down
to three and one, two and one, or one and
one, and continue their training.
As long as they don't do speed work.
Speed work is the single thing that is a deal-killer
if you're trying to heal from an injury.
>> MALE #9: How do you take those ratios to
find the best times [inaudible]?
>>Jeff Galloway: [chuckles] The question is
about how do you experiment with the various
ratios of running and walking.
And for example, he said, "Well, have you
ever tried on a three and one ratio, running
for 30 minutes and walking for ten?"
Well, I don't recommend that one because what
I found is that you get most of the benefit
from a walk break during the first 30 seconds
of that walk break.
And the longer you go beyond that, you tend
to slow down more, stiffen up, and you don't
tend to get any more benefit at all.
So, the shorter amounts of running and walking
have actually been better.
But the way that I suggest experimenting is
to devote one day during the week--a short
mileage day--and go out and try different
ratios on a measured mile course.
The first time try one ratio.
The second mile, try another one.
The third mile, try another one.
And if you do this every week and keep experimenting,
you're gonna find a ratio that works best
for you.
And you're also gonna have several different
variables if you have problems in a race.
You can shift to another one because you've
tried it before.
Question.
Yes.
>>MALE #10: [inaudible ]?
>>Jeff Galloway: How many days a week?
To stay injury-free, it's three days a week.
Three day a week runners have the lowest rate
of injury.
Although, a lot of folks, including myself
have found combinations of other things such
as walk breaks that will allow them to run
six or seven days a week.
And that's what I do and a lot of other people
do, too.
So, to get the benefit though, I'm totally
convinced now that you can run as fast on
three days a week if you include all the components
as you could on more days a week.
One of my talented friends put that to the
test.
He trained when he was going through his first
year of medical residency on three days a
week, dropping down from seven--World Class
runner.
And I dropped his mileage from 120 miles a
week down to 40 miles a week.
And after one full year, he ran a marathon
in 2:14--2:14.
And he was only four minutes behind his PR
that was set on a much easier course.
And this isn't an isolated instance.
I've heard a lot of people who are thrown
off by their job or something else and they
reduce down to three days a week.
They assume that they're not gonna be able
to run nearly as fast.
And they go to a race and totally surprise
themselves.
So anyway, three days a week are the minimum
if you really wanna stay in decent shape.
If you wanna run more than that, it's mostly
for the head.
But you know, keeping that brain in good working
order is a darn good thing and one of the
greatest aspects of my work is that I'm able
to look in to other areas that help running
and help us in the rest of our lives.
My most recent book is called "Mental Training."
And in that book, I went into how the brain
operates when we're under stress.
And most commonly, the subconscious reflex
brain starts generating negative hormones
the higher the stress level to make us feel
less and less like exercising or like pushing
through barriers.
And of course, we're producing more stress
when we have a goal and when we get out and
work hard.
So, if you can get into the frontal lobe--the
executive brain--and set up a cognitive strategy,
you can lower the stress levels slightly,
but then you can start producing positive
attitude hormones that will then change your
attitude.
And there are a whole bunch of different mental
training techniques that can keep you on that
track.
>>MALE #11: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: The question is about a tempo
run that is put in to a marathon training
program, particularly for time goals.
Now, tempo is a term that I believe doesn't
have any meaning anymore.
And the reason is that if you ask ten coaches
the definition of tempo, you're gonna get
ten different answers.
So, I really don't use it.
However, there's a race rehearsal segment
that I have in my training that ends up being
reasonably close to what I believe Ryan Hall
and Pete Pfitzinger and others term tempo.
And that is, you're trying to get yourself
to have some segment that gets up to your
race pace so that you know what that feels
like on a regular basis.
And I totally agree with that.
In our program, we have that segment on a
Tuesday.
And in that segment, I ask my athletes to
test different run/walk/run ratios at the
pace so that they dress rehearse the race
and can figure out what tends to work best
for that.
I will say that what becomes sometimes a deal-killer
for a lot of people that read my "Runner's
World" article and then ask me questions about
tempo work, is that they try in the middle
of the week to have a fairly long run of 13
to 15 miles in the middle of the week when
they're doing hard training on the weekends.
And that often is the deal-killer.
So, that is the tempo, so-called tempo, component.
It's something you need to be very careful
in doing.
I don't like to go more than about seven miles
on the race rehearsal segment that I recommend.
Yes.
>>MALE #12: Can you talk a little bit about
speed walking and also if somebody is primarily
walking, does it make sense to walk really
fast and then really slow?
>>Jeff Galloway: The question is about speed
and walking, either during a walk break, or
if you're just walking by itself.
The one problem that I have seen over and
over with walking is having too long a stride
length.
If you have a short stride and walk fast with
quicker tempo, or turnover rate, then that's
fine.
But when you lengthen that stride there are
a lot of bad things that can happen.
So, my recommendation during walk breaks is
that you keep a nice short stride, make it
easy enough so that you recover during the
walk break from your running segment.
And then, if you want to work on speeding
up the walk by having a quicker turnover rate,
then that's absolutely fine.
>>MALE #13: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: The question is about puking--
[laughter]
and I will tell you that I am against puking.
I'm against death and I'm against a few other
negatives that people bring up about running,
but those are the major ones right there.
Now, puking is something that is triggered
by several key elements.
First of all, what you ate the day before,
the night before, particularly, or during
the day before you ran your run.
So, if you're having problems with that, you
wanna minimize what you eat.
You still need to eat, but you need to minimize
it because if you're under stress and of course
you mentioned these were stressful workouts
where they occur, if you're under stress,
then your subconscious brain tries to shut
you down.
And one of the most effective ways that it
does so is by using your digestive tract in
a negative way against you.
And boy, does that get your attention.
Now, going into these workouts with a more
gentle pace in the beginning and then using
just the last portion to be the time that
you really pick up the pace is a good strategy
also.
And if it's in a long run, more frequent walk
breaks in the beginning.
And a lot of folks assume that my run/walk/run
is really just for those that are running
five and six hour marathoners, but we've had
people--over 150 people--I've heard from who
broke three hours for the first time because
the use run/walk/run.
The fastest is a fellow that improved his
time from 2:33 to 2:28 and the only thing
he changed was taking walk breaks every mile.
So, they have a lot of applicability and keep
your body from getting to that extreme point
that causes that shut-down to occur.
And then finally, mental training program
that can keep you on the edge that you want,
but keep you from going over that edge.
And there are a number of suggestions on our
websites and in the book.
And if you have any questions about that,
let me know.
John.
>>John: I actually have a question on VC from
Natasha.
Question for Jeff.
I'm training for a 5K and then a 10K and working
my way up to a marathon later on in the year.
What is the best way to prevent lower back
pain?
Also, if you already have lower back pain
from running, what are the best cures?
>>Jeff Galloway: Lower back pain and running.
Often I'm finding when I've been able to watch
people run, that the most common reason for
that is a forward lean.
It puts a lot of stress on the back and also,
it can put stress on the neck, which can also
cause pain in the back overall.
So, upright body posture.
And what I recommend is coming out of a walk
break, take a breath before you start running,
and imagine that you're a puppet on a string
with this upright body posture.
If you do it regularly, walk break after walk
break, you're gonna find that you'll have
a subtle behavioral change that will take
place over time.
But really try to make the correction more
quickly if you feel the back pain coming on.
And I've had a lot of good feedback from people
who used to have back pain who have been able
to reduce it or get away from it.
Finally, this arm running exercise with hand-held
weights going in this arm running motion has
provided extra strength throughout the shoulders,
neck, and back area and has significantly
helped people reduce their back issues.
>>MALE #14: So, what are your thoughts on
plyometric exercises, like jump squats, lunges,
stuff like that?
>>Jeff Galloway: Plyometrics, what's my stance
on that?
You know, there are all types of exercises
that people like to do.
I'm going to answer that just purely related
to running.
And for distance running, I see no benefit
at all.
But sadly, I hear from a lot of folks that
get injured and some of them have gotten very
serious knee injuries from some of those squat
jumps and things like that.
So, there's a real risk with those activities.
>>MALE #15: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: Congratulations.
He has had cramping issues in a lot of his
marathons right around the 15-mile mark.
So, I'm gonna ask you some questions.
What was the longest long run that you usually
do before these marathons where you have problems?
>>MALE #15: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: Twenty-two miles.
OK.
Generally speaking, and also what run/walk/run
ratio from the beginning, do you use in those
where you cramp?
>>MALE #15: Three and one.
>>Jeff Galloway: Three and one.
And what time are you finishing in in those
ones where you cramp?
>>MALE #15: Thirteen minute per mile.
>>Jeff Galloway: Thirteen minute per a mile.
OK.
If you go a one and one, or better a 30/30,
that should either eliminate the cramps or
they're not gonna come on 'till later on--much
later on.
Maybe the last couple miles.
But I also recommend in addition to that,
moving that long run up to at least 26 miles,
slowing them way down, and running them at
15 minutes per mile.
Now, if you do both of those, you should see
a significant time improvement provided the
weather is appropriate.
Obviously, the hotter the weather--.
I've studied the effect that hot weather has
on marathoners and it's a 30-second per mile
slowdown for every five degrees above 60.
It's significant.
And if you don't make that adjustment, it
will be made for you at the end of those marathons.
And sadly, some people wind up in the penalty
box, which is the medical tent.
And you can avoid all of that if you will
just slow down.
But a 30/30 is what my wife Barbara and I
use in our marathons.
We are currently running a marathon a month
and just enjoying the heck out of it.
We can recover very quickly, enjoy the evening,
enjoy the next day running if we want to.
It's just really a good experience to go down
like that.
And I think you're gonna find that that will
probably take away the cramping.
>>MALE #16: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: Ice baths.
What is my opinion on that?
Well, two words: cruel and unusual.
[laughter]
But I will say that soaking your legs in a
cool tub of water has been shown to allow
them to speed up the recovery.
Now that said, what the evidence is now is
that you only need a 20 degree differential
between body temperature and water temperature.
And in most cases, the cool water tap will
do that for you so you don't have to go to
the extreme of putting ice in there.
If you're in a tropical environment, you may
want to put some cubes of ice in and once
you put the water in the tub and just monitor
the temperature.
And as long as it's 78 degrees or cooler,
you're gonna soak out the excess heat just
as well as if you had ice in it.
You may not feel that you're as tough, though,
as those that go in with all the ice.
Yes.
>>MALE #17: Can you go over the proper form
of running, both stride, full stride, how
you hold your arms?
>>Jeff Galloway: OK.
The question is about running form.
What is it that I've found to be the most
efficient way to run in terms of the foot
and so forth?
Well starting with the foot, the research
is quite clear on this.
And that is that we have certain basic mechanics
that we were born with and we're gonna tend
to run in that certain way and that those
who try to depart from that are usually in
for trouble.
I mean, we can change it for a relatively
short period of time, but sooner or later,
it's simply not natural.
And something breaks.
So, anyway, I recommend going with the way
that's natural for you to run.
Now, when it comes to the most important running
motion, it's the use of the ankle.
The ankle is marvelous and it can do most
of the work of running with very little muscle
energy required.
So the way you facilitate that is to have
a relatively shorter stride with feet low
to the ground and a light touch.
So, if you have very nice gentle motion, the
ankle does most of the work.
And the calf muscle and other muscles and
the joints aren't aggravated by this.
So, it's really marvelous to see people improve
when they do this.
Moving on up the body, upright body posture
is generally best according to the research
and according to a lot of surveys that I've
done with people.
But there are a few people that naturally
lean forward.
And if you're one that naturally leans forward
and that's more natural for you, that's fine.
Still, the problem is back stress that you
could have.
When it comes to arms, just minimal arm swing
is best.
The arms really don't help you, but if you
try to move and lead with the arms, then you
can mess up your rhythm--that wonderful rhythm
that the feet and the legs naturally have.
Our ancient ancestors programmed us for walking
and running because they used to cover 15
to 20 miles a day going back more than two
million years ago.
It's natural for us to walk and to run.
And the rhythm seems to start with the feet.
And so, if we let the feet lead, running is
better.
John?
>>John: I have a question over VC from Don.
I have asthma.
And having recently noticed I'm getting cramps
under my ribs--not on my side--even when I'm
not running hard, this has been an issue for
about two weeks where my lungs seem increasingly
irritated during runs.
Is there anything I can do to release that
tightness?
>>Jeff Galloway: Yeah.
This, as far as I can get from this question,
is more related to what people call "side
pain" when they run.
And asthma has a definite role in that because
if you cannot get good absorption in the lower
lungs, then the side pain tends to kick in.
The best way to facilitate better oxygen absorption
is from the start of your run.
Try to breathe in such a way that the air
goes down into your lower lungs.
And the way you tell is whether your stomach
rises and falls.
If it's your chest rising or falling quickly,
that's panting.
And that means that you're not getting that
air going down into the lower lungs.
So, what I recommend for my athletes is when
they're walking for three to five minutes
as a warm-up, that they practice every third
or fourth breath blowing out a little bit
more and then bringing that air in so that
they're breathing with the lower lung motion.
It's the way we breathe when we're asleep.
It's the most efficient way and it really
does cut down on side pain dramatically.
>>MALE #18: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: The question is about knee
pain.
A friend of his ran a half-marathon and developed
knee pain that has not gone away.
He needs to see a doctor.
He needs to see somebody who really specializes
in running type injuries.
You're fortunate in the Bay Area to have a
lot of really good people.
One of them is a specialist who goes out to
our Tahoe camp.
We held a retreat in July every year since
1975.
The best part about it is that we have a clinician
who's a podiatrist who specializes in running.
He doesn't have to deal with any other area
because there are so many runners in the Bay
Area.
He's actually up in Marin, San Rafael.
His name is Dave Hannaford.
And even when it's a knee issue, he can often
help.
Dave is like an old line doctor.
He has the empathy for the patient.
He also has intuitive senses as well as his
technical knowledge.
And he applies this.
And he will often diagnose and treat something
with success that people who've gone to eight
or ten doctors have not been able to find
it.
Anyway, Dave Hannaford is his name.
But try to find somebody who's seen just lots
and lots of runners and have been successful
in solving these problems.
The knee is an area where there are many,
many moving parts and there are many ways
that it can get aggravated.
So, I can't really say and I can't give medical
advice anyway.
>>MALE #19: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: I don't.
I don't have any knowledge of people that
are in this area or the Southern Bay area.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #20: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: The question is about shoe
rotations.
And I do recommend that because when you find
a shoe that works, I strongly recommend you
go out and get an identical pair because the
shoe company will mess with it.
And then you have to start all over time.
But once you get that second pair, once a
week at the end of a run, put on the second
pair and run at least a quarter of a mile
in it.
Now, this gradually will break in the new
pair so you never have to go from a worn out
pair to a brand new pair.
But it does more than that.
It will give you a gauge on the old pair.
And after week after week of doing this drill,
you're gonna come to a point at some time
when the new one really feels good and old
one doesn't.
Well, you wanna shift into the new one and
use the other one as a lawn mowing pair.
Yes.
>>FEMALE #3: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: Supplements?
Any particular category of supplements?
>>FEMALE #3: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: I'm not familiar with it.
In general, I like for runners to get their
nutrition through food.
But I will absolutely tell you that the research
shows that a few days every month, the best,
most meticulous eating person is not gonna
get all the nutrients.
Now, sometimes this will not cause a problem
and sometimes it will.
I, personally, use a supplement that's researched
out of the Cooper Clinic, Dr. Kenneth Cooper
in Dallas, Texas.
He spent 15 years researching nutrition and
put out a vitamin line based on what he found.
It prevents strokes, heart disease, a lot
of other situations including certain types
of cancers.
And I figured if he spent 15 years doing it,
that I'd just follow what he thinks is best.
And that's what I use.
But there are many other reasons to have supplements.
And people have specific issues and problems.
And so, you find a supplement that can work
best for you.
But if you're not taking an overall vitamin,
I do recommend you look at least at One-A-Day
because often, even the most meticulous person
won't get enough B vitamins or iron or calcium.
There's another thing that Barbara and I suggest.
And we tested several of the sites that you
can use--websites--and the apps that allow
you to analyze your diet.
One of them if fitday.com.
Another one is sparkpeople.
They also have an app as well as a website.
And calorie king.
There's several of these.
But the bottom line is that these will give
you a chance to analyze what you're eating.
Find out if you're deficient in things on
a regular basis.
And once you do that, you can take action
and become in command of your nutritionship.
>>MALE #21: Hi.
Speaking of knee pain, I get knee pain of
the upper corner of the knee usually after
I start running after a big, long break.
I think it's ITB, but I don't know if it's
ITB or not for sure.
>>Jeff Galloway: OK.
It's about knee pain, or is your pain on the
outside of the knee?
>>MALE #21: Outside of the knee.
>>Jeff Galloway: OK.
And you get it usually when you're coming
back after a layoff.
My suggestion is that you ease your way back
into it, both in distance and in run/walk/run.
So, I would start out with mostly walking
the first week and then even amounts the second
week if everything's OK.
And the third week, you could ease into what
seems to work best for you.
But if you suddenly go out and run continuously
or run too far for you starting back, that's
when the ITB happens.
It's a wobble injury.
And what I mean is the calf muscle, which
is the major muscle in running, will get fatigued
and then the body starts wobbling.
Well, the IT band tries to hold back your
body weight and it can't do it.
>>MALE #21: Right.
>>Jeff Galloway: It gets overwhelmed.
Good news is nobody's died of iliotibial band
injury yet.
>>MALE #21: OK.
Thank you.
[laughter]
>>Jeff Galloway: We have time for two more
questions.
Yes.
>>MALE #22: [inaudible]
>>Jeff Galloway: Triathletes?
A growing number are contacting me each year
about triathlon training using run/walk/run
and it has really been extremely successful
because for one thing, when you get off the
bike and start your run, most people can walk
as fast as they can run.
But if you try to run, you're gonna put a
lot more fatigue on your legs for later on
in that run.
So, I would recommend walking for a minute
or two and then do a run/walk/run for at least
the first mile in some fashion.
And then, vary it according to what works
best for you.
My ratios do work quite well though for triathletes
and particularly Iron Man triathletes.
So, the ones that I mentioned earlier.
And you'll find those on jeffgalloway dot
com.
And feel free to ask any questions, also.
My website again is jeffgalloway dot com.
It's free.
We have a lot of information up there.
And you can ask me questions and there's no
charge for that.
You can simply, if you put Google in the subject
line as a code word, then you will get a faster
response than other people.
[laughter]
So, anyway.
>>John: Two things.
First off, I just wanted to let everyone know
that Google is currently offering a discount
on multivitamins and DHA to Googlers.
It was announced in the January Perks newsletter.
So, take advantage of that if you haven't
already.
It'll probably be run again in February.
We're still working out the details.
Also, one question for you, Jeff, is around
frequency of breathing.
How often do you recommend inhaling and exhaling?
Is it every couple strides and how deep?
>>Jeff Galloway: OK.
With breathing frequency, first of all, I
am in favor of breathing.
I am definitely in favor of it.
But seriously, the frequency is very individual,
but what has been shown in a lot of research
is that if you're increasing your breathing
rate--your huffing and puffing rate--this
is a direct sign that your effort level is
rising and that your heart rate is rising
also.
So, on most of the runs, particularly the
long, easy runs, I recommend that there be
no excessive huffing and puffing--that you
breathe naturally so that you can carry on
a conversation.
Now, on speed work, if you're doing some of
that, there will be some huffing and puffing
there.
And at that point, there is no magic formula
because I see it all over the place.
Where I see people getting in trouble is when
they let their panting get out of control.
As long as you're having every third or fourth
breath that is lower lung breath, then you're
gonna tend to get good absorption out of that.
But if you're panting all the time, you're
not gonna get as good absorption.
So John, I'll turn it back over to you.
>>John: Thank you, Jeff.
If we can get a round of applause for coming
out here.
[applause]